what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video before we get into
the details I just want to give everyone
two heads up about the giveaway that I'm
doing the second winner has been
randomly selected and I will announce
your name at the end of this video there
is still one prize left to win so make
sure you enter that way you get your
chance at getting either the world of
ice and fire novel or the Game of
Thrones monopoly game I'm not sure what
the new winner will pick as their prize
but whatever of the two prizes are left
you can still win make sure you stay
until the end of this video because you
could be the next winner I am going to
announce but if you haven't entered the
giveaway yet the link will be down in
the description of this video now let's
get into the news there is so much going
on in the game of Thrones community this
week I'm not really sure where to begin
but I guess I can start off with some of
the exciting news this week HBO has
announced who they will use as directors
for the six remaining episodes in their
epic series this news came out a few
days ago but if you haven't heard then
you should be pretty excited about this
- thankfully HBO brought back Miguel
supports nake who will direct more than
one of the six remaining episodes if you
don't remember who Miguel supports Nick
is and I will remind you
Miguel was best known for directing
episodes like hardhome battle with the
Basterds and winds of winter you know
he's only known for directing some of
the most iconic episodes in Game of
Thrones history personally I was very
happy to hear this news because Miguel
might be my favorite director HBO has
ever hired for Game of Thrones I think
when it comes to action set pieces or
even tension building Miguel supports
[ __ ] top notch I actually posted a
tweet on Twitter months ago asking HBO
to bring Miguel back for the final
season because I think he could direct
the great war against the night king
better than anyone else in television
right now but that's just my opinion the
next director HBO hired for season 8 is
another familiar name David Nutter will
also be directing several episodes in
the final season now if you don't
remember who David Nutter is then I will
remind you of this - David Nutter is
best known for directing a little
episode called the rains of castamere
also known as the red wedding arguably
one of the most iconic episodes in
television history
I have to say I am pleased with both
directors this is a little relieving
knowing that HBO brought back some of
their veterans to finish off this series
in style but there is also two other
people they picked to direct a finale
the very last episode in season eight
will be directed by Dan and Dave the two
show runners of Game of Thrones this
news was a little bit controversial when
it came out because many fans are not
happy with these two men because they
are responsible for writing this show
which people have not been satisfied
with the last few seasons and now they
are deciding to direct the last episode
personally I was hoping they would get
another veteran director to cap off this
series but it is what it is I can only
hope for the best but let me know what
you think about this decision down below
now let's get on to the casting news
because I found this to be interesting
as well HBO is looking to hire seven new
actors for new roles in the final season
I always love casting news because this
always creates some new and fun
speculation throughout the community the
first actor they are looking for is a
northern farmer between ages 25 to 35
years old he's a straightforward honest
man of simple tastes who works on the
land the roll is scheduled to begin its
filming around November 17th and it's
kind of hard to say exactly who this
could be we could see another meeting at
Winterfell before the war begins and
this new character could have a few
lines during that meeting or this could
just be someone John and Daenerys meet
along their way up to Winterfell John
and Daenerys are currently sailing
towards white Harbor where they will
then travel to Winterfell so they could
meet some people as they head north and
this new actor could be that person or
this could be somebody that warns people
that the White Walkers and whites are
heading south and this character could
have gotten word that villages are being
destroyed by the others but I'm not
quite sure yet the second character will
be a sassy and attractive girl aged 18
to 25 years old the character is a sexy
and confident northern girl playing a
good memorable one scene part in one
Episode playing opposite the leading
cast this role was set to start filming
around November 6th now with this
character we definitely know she will be
in the same room as the leading cast for
her part in
a northern girl so this could definitely
be a meeting type scene in Winterfell as
they plan their attack or defenses there
is one more northern character they are
looking to cast a northern century age
18 to 25 years old this is another
character that will play their part with
the leading cast in the north it's a
small part but it says he needs to have
great timing so this could perhaps be a
scene that provides some comedy relief
before things get really ugly
this character should begin filming
sometime in December another role
they're looking to fill was a new sailor
aged 35 to 50 years old he's a
rough-and-ready seafaring type with a
weathered face and strong presence this
part is scheduled to start filming in
December as well this definitely sounds
like somebody from the Ironborn this
could be someone from Euron's crew or
possibly even Theon's we might see a new
character from one of their groups get
an actual speaking role in the final
season Joran is heading to get the
golden company and Theon is heading to
rescue Yara so I can only assume we're
gonna get several scenes with the
Ironborn in season 8 so this does make
sense to hire someone like this the
final two roles HBO is looking to fill
for Game of Thrones Season 8 is for two
guards one guard is in his 20s and one
guard is in his thirties it doesn't say
whether they are northerners or
southerners so these guards could pop up
literally anywhere all it says is they
need to be physically fit with the
military type feel to them they could
potentially be guarding anything these
guards could even be in volantis if
there is a scene of Melisandre or can
vara there Melisandre said she was going
to volantis then she was coming back I
think it would be cool if these were the
guards at the temple in volantis but
they could also be guards in King's
Landing or possibly a white Harbor it's
really hard to say at this point there
just really isn't enough details
actually you know what I'm sorry there
is a location for guard number two it
says that guard will be filming in Spain
which is typically where they filmed for
King's Landing or Dragonstone it does
say he will be filming what the leading
cast - which could be Cersei and Euron
or it could even be John and Daenerys
one and if they come back down to King's
Landing to take care of Cersei I do
expect to see at least two big Wars next
season one against the night king and
one against Cersei we probably will see
a few smaller bad
mixed in there but I think there will be
two major wars in the final season but
if you have any opinions on who you
think these new characters could be
please put it down in the comments
because I'd love to hear any new ideas
from you a report also came out about
the budget for Game of Thrones season 8
as well and this is really good news too
Game of Thrones has always been known
for having one of the biggest budgets
per episode in television history but in
season eight the budget is even bigger
HBO will be spending fifteen million
dollars per episode in season eight
which is five million more dollars per
episode than they did before that's
actually an astronomical amount of money
being spent on each episode when you
compare it to other TV shows with that
much money I can only imagine how great
the CGI will be in the final episode and
drug on will probably be even bigger
than before we will see more scenes with
the whites and White Walkers - and with
Miguel supports NIC directing the
battles I have a feeling it's going to
be legendary think of something like
hardhome and battle of the bastards but
on steroids
there was also reports that each episode
would be somewhere around 90 minutes
long which could explain for the bigger
budget but considering this is the last
season I know they want to end this with
a grand finale something that will be
talked about for years to come
and one last thing before I announce the
second prize winner of the giveaway I
actually have a question for all of you
well any of you be attending Cana
Thrones this year it's being held in
Dallas Texas this year and tickets have
already gone on sale I'm definitely
gonna be there this time and I would
love to meet up with some of you and
have some drinks or dinner and [ __ ] like
that if you want I think it would be
cool to finally meet some of you that
can make it there so let me know if
you're gonna be attending Cana thorns
this year because we want to schedule a
time to meet up down there alright now
it's time to announce the second winner
of the three prize giveaway keep in mind
there is still one prize left to win
after this but today's winner is Cara
McNamee Congrats Cara you're gonna have
to contact me via email or private
message me here on youtube and let me
know which address to send your prize to
you get to pick between the world of ice
and fire novel or the Game of Thrones
Monopoly game and whichever prize she
does not pick will be given away to the
next person randomly selected within the
next week so make sure you enter the
giveaway because you can still win some
thing and this won't be the last
giveaway I do either I already have a
new one in mind once this one ends and I
will start a new giveaway immediately
after I ship the last prize in this one
so thank you all for participating and
thank you all for your continued support
because it really does mean a lot to me
I hope everybody has a great day and I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]